con la ratificación de ayer por la noche
del parlamento Turco de la entrada de
Finlandia a la otan se abre un pequeño
proceso de formalidades que culminarán
la semana que viene en Bruselas con una
ceremonia de la adhesión definitiva de
Finlandia a esta organización
transanántica que se convertirá en el 31
países que forma parte de esta
organización tenía que entrar Finlandia
conjuntamente con Suecia con quien
aplicó a la vez para formar parte de la
otan pero no va a ocurrir por el veto de
Turquía que sigue manteniéndole en
contra de estocolmo sobre todo Turquía
se queja amargamente de que Suecia se ha
convertido en palabras del pueblo y
presidente Turco recepta de perdón en un
nido de terroristas Turquía le ha dado a
Suecia una lista con 124 nombres de
personas supuestamente vinculadas Son
miembros de varias organizaciones que
Turquía consiste de terroristas como lo
son sobre todo la guerrilla kurdo turca
del pkka estas deportaciones no han
ocurrido hasta la fecha no se prevé que
ocurran porque la justicia sueca ha
dirigido en la gran mayoría los casos
que si estas personas fuesen deportadas
a Turquía no recibirían en suelo Turco
un juicio justo sin embargo la gran
mayoría de los expertos considera que el
veto Turco podrá ser levantado después
de esta Primavera Y es que el 14 de mayo
se celebrarán en Turquía elecciones
presidenciales en las que erdogan se
juega Su futuro político muy debilitado
con su prioridad en bajo mínimos
históricos según esos expertos intenta
mostrarse como un hombre duro ante
Europa y ante la otan para intentar
galvanizar a sus votantes que según las
en la gran mayoría de las encuestas
ahora mismo favorecen más al Principal
candidato de la oposición turca